I think presidents are basically like
great white sharks they do what they do
like you put a seal in the water with a
great white shark the seal the shark
will go after it if you're a surfer in a
wetsuit the shark might think you're a
seal you don't really believe the shark
hi I'm Nick Gillespie with Reason TV and
today we're talking with Chris Edelson
he's an assistant professor at the
School of Public Affairs at American
University and the author of emergency
presidential power from the drafting of
the Constitution to the war on terror
Chris thanks for joining
oh thanks very much appreciate it let's
start with somebody like Obama yes you
know Obama last summer was basically
about to declare war unilaterally on
Syria you wrote against that that power
in the LA Times last summer it infuses
your book is Obama overly broad in
interpreting executive power yeah I
would think I would say he's making many
of the same mistakes and doing some many
of the same dangerous things that Bush
did and what's ironic about that of
course is Obama's a constitutional
lawyer and scholar a bad background used
to teach classes in the Constitution
University of Chicago when he ran for
president in 2008 he said Bush was
violating the rule of LOB we were going
to restore it I'm going to put us back
in a track under the Constitution and I
have to say I was glad to hear that
turns out during this presidency I don't
think he's followed and Syria is one
really good example of that yeah and I
Libby is another example for some of the
Ray si you know his defense of that or
his idea of you know an executive kill
list yes that's right but be a part of
what your book talks about is that this
is not well you know it's something new
it's happening now but it's not exactly
new right let's talk about a couple of
big examples that are in the book from
the past and one is about Abraham
Lincoln and you know the suspension of
habeas corpus in 9/11 is rather during
the surgeon service area so how did how
do you talk about that in the book and
what what's the enduring lesson oh yeah
thanks for asking about that one reason
I got interested in writing this books I
wanted to understand what's happened
since September 11th and a lot of times
defenders of broad presidential power
will say nothing news going on this is
just what Lincoln did during the war
during World War two I think that's a
specious argument I don't think it's
really right Lincoln did take some
extraordinary measures as you said
suspending habeas corpus unilaterally
the beginning of the Civil War he
conceded he was acting extra extra
constitutionally he went to Congress
sent a message them on July 4th 1861 and
said I've done certain things like
suspending habeas corpus he also called
up the military or spending for the
military ordered a blockade of the South
all things that are really within
Congress's sphere Authority what he said
to Congress is some of these things were
not strictly legal
so really frankly admitted I acted
beyond my power and he said I'm asking
you to recognize this was an emergency
and I think he was right this is one of
the rare cases there really wasn't
emergency the country was breaking into
he said I had to act Congress wasn't in
session and he conceded that he needed
their approval and they gave it to him
so I think it's different than what's
happened now and and you could also
argue and again I can realize this going
in many different directions that the
Civil War in 1861 say or 1861 America is
different than 2012 course fourteen
America right talk about Harry Truman
yeah he's a you know his kind of
extraordinary yes so that's another key
so the Civil War is certainly one key
point when it comes to broad
presidential power though I would argue
there were limits and Lincoln recognized
presidential power since World War two
and really Truman's a good key marking
point has expanded with almost you know
without the same kind of limits Lincoln
recognized Truman of course first sent
troops to Korea in 1950 after saying
when the United Nations Charter was
ratified there was a question members of
Congress said senators who would have to
approve the treaty said wait if we
approve this does that mean you'll be
able to send troops in unilaterally
Truman State cabled back I think it was
in Potsdam at the time and said no I
won't I will always check with you first
in 1947 Congress passed a law that's at
the UN participation act that said
Congress still has to approve military
action so there's this kind of incorrect
belief in American life that the United
Nations Charter allows Member States to
go to war unilaterally it doesn't the
Charter itself says constitutions still
apply so just because the United Nations
authorizes actually like it did in Korea
it doesn't mean US law goes away
president still needs authority under
the Constitution
Truman acted unilaterally unfortunately
Congress didn't stop him and he created
a precedent a precedent argues incorrect
but a precedent nonetheless it doesn't
$1 is a living under because yes I've
been an actual declaration that's
reference there have been often like the
authorization for the use of military
force but presidents pretty routinely
including Obama in in almost in Syria
and he sort of reserved the right there
and in Libya they claimed the right to
act as Truman did to act unilaterally in
certain cases that I don't think are
supported by the Constitution a Truman
you're right really started out with
Korea and you actually have a kind of
interesting take on the War Powers Act
which came out of the Knicks in New York
and Vietnam and whatnot and it was it's
widely seen as an attempt to restrain
the president by saying that they have
if they dispatch troops in an immediate
threat and they have to come back and
get authorization from Congress or file
a report it's not clear you know that
that I mean Obama didn't do that for the
Libya engagement he did file a report
but I would argue didn't follow the act
you're right and but you actually argue
that it's unconstitutional but for kind
of novel grants not because write limits
the president but exactly because it
gives the president too much power so
the War Powers Resolution is just a law
I mean laws are laws but they're they're
subordinate to the Constitution that's
when a Marbury vs. Madison
if the War Powers Resolution violates
the Constitution it doesn't apply and
the court critics defenders abroad
presidential power like John you I read
about in the book would say the War
Powers Resolution is unconstitutional
because it limits presidential power his
positions the president can do whatever
the president wants in military affairs
my position is actually different I
would say the War Powers Resolution as
you said is unconstitutional because it
expands presidential power I think the
framers very clearly said there in the
debate at Philadelphia in 1787 the only
time when the president can act
unilaterally with the military is to
repeal a sudden attack the War Powers
Resolution partly because it's not very
clearly written seems at least arguably
gives more power than that in to the
extent that it does I would already it's
unconstitutional is since 9/11 now I I
mean it's it's not simply and and some
of the cases in your book too it's not
simply about military or right kind of
you know actions like that press since
9/11 there seems to be an even broader
kind of expansive understanding of
executive power executive privilege
things like that where are some of the
areas you see that are not directly
related to military engagement or even
the war on
right the presidency is kind of out of
control that's a great point
so the obvious when you talk about
emergency power the first thing you
think of is the military but it doesn't
the Bush administration for instance use
this kind of power the area of
warrantless surveillance in the area of
torture and there the detention system
at Guantanamo the Obama administration
has used it in the the killer capture
this that you talked about I think in
some ways it supports this this metadata
program the NSA has been using of course
what you said about Syria is an example
that's the military though so those are
some of the areas that leave to mind
what about you know a lot of people on
the right especially so the way that
Obama is acting in unilaterally refusing
to implement certain aspects of Obama
already laying there laying that is that
part and parcel of this broad move
towards a robust interpretation of
executive power or is that something
different it's separate I think what it
concerns me for similar reasons so if
you believe in broad presidential power
like the unitary executive theory which
I read about which Dick Cheney really
supports the unitary executive theory
basically says the president when he's
operating in areas of executive power as
defined by the president can do what he
wants now I focus on that in the context
of national security and foreign affairs
but it has implications in direct
domestic affairs as well and you're
right so when Obama says the Affordable
Care Act I want to put off the employer
mandate for a year well that concerns me
I mean the reason it concerns me is
because the president he is setting is
that presidents can decide what part of
laws they want to fall in with and they
don't and this is not just about kind of
discretion to you know focus on certain
laws because we all know that you know
that the government can enforce all of
the insane well sure rights every year
so this is not about discretion this is
really a fundamental change in what a
law means I I'm concerned I guess I
won't say unequivocally that I reach a
conclusion but I'm certainly concerned
about that there are defenders of his
who argue while other presidents have
delayed laws and that's true it's
happened before does that make it okay
I'm not sure and again and and Obama
himself will defend it by saying well
I'm not trying to undermine a law and of
course that's true he wants Obama care
to work but the problem is future
presidents might have different agendas
and it does concern me well let's to
no question let's go back to something
you were saying about President Obama
you know as candidate Obama he was
really clear on what the constitutional
limits of the executive branch were yes
he gets into power and suddenly he has
amnesia about that is there any way to
restrain the executive from just taking
as much power as they can get away I
think I'm I hope so if if not then the
system doesn't work me basically have a
third cherian regime so here's the way I
think about it because I've been
confused about this - why was Obama
saying this is a dream maybe it's just
Apocrypha I don't know it's really
second week we give him we should give
him the benefit that meant it when he
said fair point absolutely right and in
a sense it doesn't really matter these
I've concluded here's what I've
concluded about it
I think presidents are basically like
great white sharks they do what they do
like you put a seal in the water with a
great white shark the shark will go
after it if you're a surfer in a wetsuit
the shark might think you're a seal you
don't really blame the shark president
and the framers knew this the framers
said if men were angels we wouldn't need
government and we wouldn't need to
oversee government you cannot assume
that any president is going to be
anything other than someone seeking
power and seeking to advance ourselves
so it's the checks more come from
Congress the press the courts and the
people I would say in maybe to an extent
this has happened sometimes lawyers
within the executive branch we're
willing to stand up which sometimes
happens
well then very quickly final question
like how do we how do we either put a
spine sir I don't know if you can
transplant spines or not how do we get
Congress to have a spine or how do we
elect a congress that does be great for
all this talk about gridlock I mean the
real problem is that you know Congress
doesn't do its duty which is in many
ways to restrain the executive of course
I want said yes it's an important
problem and I'm afraid to say I don't
have a great answer that the the scholar
who wrote the foreword to my book my
name Lou Fisher worked for the
Congressional Research Service for about
35 years
he's probably think he's fair to say the
Dean of scholarship in this area and
he's a big advocate of Congress
reasserting itself and I think he's
right about that the problem is you say
is that what I always wonder is how
exactly does that happen I don't know I
think probably there this raises
probably important problems about larger
issues in the system how members of
Congress are elected the role of money
in projects things like that time I mean
but perhaps
in the in the wake of Nixon or something
whether a time where Congress actually
acted in a trans partisan way to
restrain the power oh sure yeah
absolutely you're right I mean you
mentioned the War Powers Resolution that
was clearly an attempt to limit
presidential power the Foreign
Intelligence Surveillance Act was passed
in 1970 the non detention Act was passed
in 1971 intended to prevent sort of
another mass internment so yes there
have been sort of brief periods like
this maybe a little bit after
iran-contra as well but unfortunately
because it's government the rules don't
work and it's ineffective well that
that's an interesting question that I
would argue I guess that if rules don't
work maybe they can be fixed and we're
the reasoner that's a theoretical point
though and the reason I want to be
hopeful so I want to hope that something
can be done so I guess I would say if
something doesn't work like the War
Powers Resolution as you pointed out I
think it doesn't but my my answer would
be let's make it work and be and the
reason I say that it's because I'm
concerned ultimately if it doesn't work
there were a couple of law professors
wrote a book called the executive
unbound after the Madisonian republic
and their argument basically was
presidents are unrestrained they should
be unrestrained there's nothing we can
or should do about it the law can't stop
them and that my response would be well
if that's the case we don't have a
constitutional democracy you're voting
straight putin in the next life yeah
excuse me
well we will leave it there we've been
talking with Chris Adelson an assistant
professor at the School of Public
Affairs at American University and the
author of emergency presidential power
from the drafting of the Constitution of
the war on terror it's from University
of Wisconsin yes thanks so much thank
you very much talking to us I am
Nicholas b4 recent TV